I'm Nora Donna with Gayle King and John
Dickerson we start with this this
morning Sri Lankans president is asking
his country's police chief and defense
minister to resign after officials
failed to act on warnings ahead of
Sunday's terror attacks at least 359
people are now reported killed in a
string of suicide bombings at churches
and hotels on Easter Sunday
police say 60 people have been arrested
in connection with the attacks the US
Embassy in Sri Lanka says it had no
prior knowledge of any threats
ambassadors said this morning she
believes terrorist groups are still
plotting possible attacks inside that
country Isis released this video
claiming that it shows a group of
suicide bombers that took part in the
attacks after pledging allegiance to the
terror group Isis has offered no other
evidence to back up its claim of
responsibility CBS News senior national
security contributor Michael Morell
joins us from Washington he's a former
deputy director and acting director of
the CIA and is the host of intelligence
matters podcast good morning Mike good
morning so two days passed before Isis
claimed responsibility what does this
tell you about what role Isis may or may
not have actually played in this bombing
so John there's two possibilities right
one is that they somehow directed the
attack the other is that they simply
inspired it the fact that it took them
two days to claim responsibility
suggests to me that it might be the
latter inspired rather than the former
directed because if they directed it
they would have known from the get-go
that that they played a role so it's
suggestive of inspiration rather than
direction but I think it's gonna take
some time for us to figure out that
exactly it was so well coordinated I
mean the number of attacks does that
suggest some foreign interference or
help so it does on the surface but I
think one thing we have to be conscious
of is that the Sri Lankan security
services are not strong I think it's
even fair to say they're inept so you
have to look at the capabilities of the
terrorist group are relative to the
security service that they're running up
against
what's interesting to me is less the
fact that they didn't do enough with the
warning they were given and more of the
fact that all of this happened right
underneath their nose and they didn't
see any of it that's more interesting to
me and it really suggests that that that
they need significant strengthening as a
security service I want to get your take
on a couple big stories out this morning
that involve Russian interference in our
elections first Jared Kushner one of the
presidents closest advisors was here in
New York he rarely does interviews and
he suggested yesterday that the multiple
investigations into Russian election
interference were more harmful to
American democracy than essentially the
original interference let's listen to
what he said you look at you know what
Russia did you know binds from facebook
ads to try to sow dissent and do it and
it's a terrible thing but I think the
investigations and and all the the
speculation has happened for the last
two years has had a much harsher impact
on democracy than a couple of Facebook
as was it just Facebook ads that Russia
was involved in no the Russians across
the whole range of activities from
stealing information and giving it to
WikiLeaks to trying to get inside state
and local voting systems to the use of
their overt media RT and Sputnik to
everything they did on social media it
was he it was a very significant and
extensive interference and and Jared is
trying to downplay this a little bit bit
by saying a few ads right we're talking
about ads that reached over a hundred
million people so this was a very
significant attack and the investigation
never would have occurred had the attack
never occurred so I think the attack is
the most significant thing here well it
was very multifaceted they were trying
to get in lots of different points and
of course the reason this is important
is not just what happened in the past
but what is happening in the future in
the New York Times has a piece this
morning that said former Department of
Homeland Security Secretary Kirsten
Neilson was told by Mick Mulvaney the
acting chief of staff not to bring up
new Russian interference efforts in
front of the president because the
president it would
the president angry what does that tell
you how significant is that so it's
absolutely clear to me and it's
absolutely clear to US intelligence
officials and we know this from public
testimony by the Director of National
Intelligence that it is highly likely
that the Russians are going to come back
and play a significant role in the 2020
election and that we should expect new
approaches new new things that they're
gonna do to try to get around the
defenses that we put in place that means
to me there needs to be a very
significant effort on the part of the US
government to defend ourselves and that
really requires the leadership of the
President and if he's not providing that
leadership then I really worry about
whether our government is going to be
ready for the attack that is almost
certainly coming all right you'll be
calling the White House to let them know
that when right away it really is some
stunning reporting in the New York Times
about whether you have a White House led
a multifaceted way to push back against
these cyber attacks and other things
Michael we're always good to have you
thank you so much